so der nächste redner ist an martin
vierte wand für die europäischen linken
sie ja auch schon angekündigt haben
ursula von der leyen nicht zu wenigen
und bürgern und ich habe in den letzten
tagen hunderte wenn nicht tausende
e-mails bekommen die wahrscheinlich
viele andere kolleginnen und kollegen
auch die sich mit ihrer nominierung
auseinandersetzen und ich möchte die
gelegenheit nutzen neben europäischen
dem aus die auch das wort zu erteilen
indem ich aus einer dieser e-mails
zitiere da steht als wählerin erwarte
ich dass das parlament einen der
spitzenkandidaten zum präsidenten bzw
zur präsidentin der europäischen
kommission wählt und die dame aus deren
e mails gerade zitiere setzt dann fort
die ernennung einer
verteidigungsministerin zur
kommissionspräsidentin wäre aus meiner
sicht eine entscheidung mit fataler
signalwirkung dass die eu einen kurs in
richtung militarisierung und abschottung
nimmt ich finde an dieser stelle ist
weder der kritik am verfahren ihrer
nominierung noch am inhalt etwas
hinzuzufügen
und ich möchte auf das treffen bezug
nehmen was wir in der letzten woche
hatten sie waren in der linksfraktion
haben ihre idee ihre vision von der
europäischen zukunft vorgestellt und als
deutlich geworden dass unsere vision
eine andere ist und ich werde es an
dieser stelle auch begründen wir lehnen
als einzige fraktion hier im haus
geschlossen die fortsetzungen der
austeritätspolitik ab wenn jemand wie
sie mehr wie sie von der zukunft europa
spricht der muss meiner ansicht nach
endlich mit dieser falschen neoliberalen
ideologie brechen die sparpolitik liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen hat eben nicht
dazu geführt dass zb die staatshaushalte
saniert worden sind sondern ganz im
gegenteil sie hat ausschließlich dazu
geführt dass zum beispiel öffentliche
investitionen nicht mehr vorgenommen
werden konnten das in bildung nicht mehr
investiert wurde das im
gesundheitsschutz sich wer investiert
wurde und auch dass keine mittel zur
verfügung stand unentschieden gegen den
klimawandel zu kämpfen und die
leidtragenden dieser politik die
leidtragenden dieser politik sind die
bürgerinnen und bürger in der gesamten
europäischen union und frau von der
leyen werden klima notstand bekämpfen
will der muss jetzt handeln und wer den
wirtschaftlichen strukturwandel
bewältigen will
der muss jetzt investieren und wer für
soziale sicherheit garantieren will in
der europäischen union
er muss jetzt mit dieser falschen
austeritätspolitik brechen 113 millionen
menschen das sind offizielle zahlen der
kommission 113 millionen menschen leben
in der europäischen union in armut oder
sind von armut betroffen und da erwarte
ich von einer kommissionspräsident
schafft's kandidatinnen mehr als blumige
worte da erwarte ich dass sie hier
stehen und sagen ja ich habe verstanden
wir brauchen eine soziale offensive für
die europäische union
mein ziel ist es dass in fünf jahren
keine europäische bürgerinnen und kein
europäischer bürger mehr egal welchen
alters und egal in welcher region von
existenznot betroffen ist sondern ein
würdevolles leben führen kann
und dafür braucht es natürlich die
finanziellen voraussetzungen aber zb im
bereich der steuerpolitik sind sie heute
ja leider sehr vage geblieben ich sage
ihnen samthandschuhe sind das falsche
werkzeug um für steuergerechtigkeit zu
sorgen ich erwarte von einer kandidatin
für die kommissionspräsident schafft den
entschiedenen willen und den mut sich
auch mit den konzernen anzulegen zu
sagen hier ganz klar ja ich will das
steuerdumping beenden ich will die
steueroasen auch in der europäischen
union schließen
und ich würde konzerne und vermögenden
endlich wieder gerecht einem
steueraufkommen beteiligen und für
steuergerechtigkeit sorgen um weitere
milliarden sollen ja jetzt in die
aufrüstung der europäischen union
gesteckt werden das haben sie auch noch
einmal deutlich gemacht das ist also
geld was zb für die soziale sicherheit
für gesundheit für bildung et cetera
fehlen wird und das wird eben nicht in
die öffentliche daseinsvorsorge fließen
sondern zum beispiel in moderne
waffensysteme manch einer träumt ja
heutzutage sogar schon von einer
weltraum armee ich finde das ehrlich
gesagt eher ein alptraum
aber ob sie nun von einer europäischen
armee oder von einer armee die europäer
sprechen das ist für mich wortklauberei
an der stelle war das ziel ist ganz klar
das ergebnis ist eine aufrüstung der
europäischen union und einer
militarisierung der außenpolitik und das
leben wir als links fraktion im
europäischen parlament entschieden ab
wir fordern eine eu strategie zur
stärkung diplomatische konflikt lösung
oder ein er
der schritt wäre unserer ansicht nach
die einberufung einer internationalen
abrüstungskonferenz in einem letzten
punkt durch die noch erwähnen die
europäischen außengrenzen sind derzeit
die tödlichsten grenzen der welt und ich
halte das für eine politische
bankrotterklärung europäischer politik
das jeden tag menschen im mittelmeer
sternen müssen während diejenigen die
die universellen menschenrechte
verteidigen in einigen mitgliedsstaaten
kriminalisiert werden
frau von der leyen ich habe sehr genau
zugehört was ihr vorhin dazu gesagt
haben wir werden als den fraktionen sehr
genau darauf achten was sie versuchen
kleine politik umzusetzen
ich denke aber dass unser plan und dass
es deutlich geworden für die zukunft der
europäischen union einer sozialen
europäischen union einer klimagerechten
europäischen union einer friedlichen
europäischen union mit ihrer version
wenig kompatibel ist und deswegen werden
heute leider nicht für sie stimmen
können vielen dank
zunächst gerieten gestern nigel farage
der wahlsieger der oper wollen